The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at osw.mit.edu.
LARRY ABBOTT: So I
put this slide up
so you could walk in and
say, I came to this course
to learn about high level
cognition machines that
do amazing things.
Surely this guy's not
going to talk about a fly.
But I am going to
talk about a fly.
And I will try in the beginning
to explain to you why.
And hopefully, by
the end, we'll see.
I won't declare victory at
all, and you can tell me
if it applies or whatever.
The reason I'm talking about
the fly is this quote, really.
Flies are in all sorts
of mushroom bodies.
I'm going to talk about a
part of the fly brain called
the mushroom body.
And mushroom bodies are
in all sorts of insects.
And I kind of like this quote.
We more like to say the mushroom
body is the soul of the fly.
But what I want to point out
here is this part of the quote.
Flies are not as
intelligent as you,
but they're
intelligence, much of it,
comes from this small part of
the brain called the mushroom
body.
If you have free will,
they have free will.
But unlike you, we can here
point to a part of the brain
and say, that's where it is.
And I'll try to convince
you of that as we go on.
And so that's why I'm
talking about a fly.
You can really say there's this
small part of the brain called
the mushroom body--
I'll show it to
you in a second--
where maybe not uniquely,
but certainly is
a point at which
intelligent behavior arises,
in which something like
free will, whatever
makes different flies
do different things
on different occasions arises.
Now, not only that,
again, compared
to what you might
know in a mammal,
this is a region of the
brain where all the cell
types are known.
There's genetic control
over all the cell types.
There is a very good
optical level anatomy.
And very soon, there'll
be an EM level anatomy.
So it's a region of the
brain that has all of that.
And so I thought it would
be a good example of where
the limits of knowledge
of neuroscience
are really extended out.
You have to put up
with it's only a fly.
Sure, it's kind of
a stupid animal.
But I'll show you some behaviors
and what this thing can do,
and we'll see how it will go.
And maybe just some
machine learning.
So these are the
people involved.
This is a talk in which the
fraction of the work that I did
is not zero, but it's
very, very small.
And so much of it is
done in collaboration
with Richard Axel and members
of his lab, of whom all
of these-- you
can see the names.
Ann is a theory student
who worked with me.
But an awful lot of the
work is done at Janelia
in a collaboration with
Jerry Rubin's group,
and in particular, Yoshi Aso
did a huge amount of work here.
So I feel just fortunate to
be able to kind of correct
the commas on the paper.
That was my role
in this project.
So that's the people.
OK, so what is the
mushroom body all about?
This is a diagram of
the olfactory system.
I should have said
at the beginning,
not only is it flies,
it's olfaction.
Two of the most--
can you pick a more boring sense
and a more boring creature?
So anyway, let's give it a try.
So flies have receptors
along their antenna.
The don't have a
nose, but that's
where the olfactory
receptors are.
I'll show you in a schematic
a little bit later.
There are neurons that
receive the odors,
then send a signal
to this structure.
This is called
the antennal lobe.
And at that point,
it gets relayed
from these set of neurons
to a set of neurons
called projection neurons.
Those go up here, and
they send their signal
to the mushroom body.
And the mushroom body is
this kind of L-shaped thing
here that I'll describe
in more detail.
And then they also send axons
to another region of the brain
called the lateral horn.
I'll come back to that.
I think I'll come back to that.
Maybe I should say it
now so I don't forget.
So as you'll see,
the mushroom body
is going to be responsible
for learned behaviors,
is responsible for learned
behaviors in the fly.
And the lateral
horn is responsible
for innate behaviors.
You'll see at the
end of the talk,
actually, evidence of that.
So there's a division which
actually occurs in your brain
too of the olfactory
pathway to an innate
pathway and a more
flexible learned pathway.
So this is a diagram.
This is, again, from
the Janelia work
of real pictures of the stuff.
It's overlaid on a fly brain.
You don't see the
periphery here,
but these are the
antennal lobes.
So this is this relay
station in the fly brain.
Here is one of the projection
neurons you see here.
This is the mushroom body.
Again, this L-shaped thing.
And then it goes backwards.
So that purple are the cell
bodies of the mushroom body.
And here you can see it, again,
going to the lateral horn.
This is the optic part of the
fly brain for doing olfaction.
This is obviously a
schematic of the stages
of olfaction in the fly.
These are supposed
to be the receptors,
so let me start with them.
They're called olfactory
receptor neurons.
There are about 1,000 of them.
They come in around 50 types.
And here the types have
been drawn in colors.
And what a type means
is a cell that expresses
a single receptor molecule.
So it will bind to a
set of odors, whatever
that particular molecule does.
And so all of these
red guys are virtually
identical in their responses.
All of the green guys
are identical, et cetera.
And there are 50 types.
And I'll show you
in a second, they
form about a 30-dimensional
representation
of olfactory space.
Not as high as in your nose.
Not nearly as high
as in a mouse's nose.
But that's what you get.
OK, as I mentioned,
these project
to this structure, which
is the antennal lobe
in my little diagram.
And they have the
property that all
of the cells of a certain
type, in other words expressing
a particular receptor, project
to the same site, which
is called a glomerulus.
So you can see all the red
guys go to the red one.
All the purple guys to
the purple one, et cetera.
So this is an incredibly
precise wiring
getting these 50 olfactory
signals from the 50 types
to a point in space,
or a region in space.
And that's the point at
which the next cells--
so this is obviously
the input layer.
I'm sort of over here,
giving you computer language,
if you want, for all this.
So at this point, you have
the projection neurons
pick up the signal.
There are about
200 of them, again,
in the exact same 50
types, because there
are a few projection
neurons for each
of these different glomeruli.
And they send the signal
onto the mushroom body,
and as I mentioned,
the lateral horn,
although we won't talk about
that whole lot until the end.
And this is a
one-to-one connection.
So every projection neuron--
let's say there are
red type projection
neurons that just pick up the
red signal, send it onward.
There are purple type
guys-- they're not really
called this-- but they accept
these 50 signals, maintain them
as separate pathways.
So what's this thing doing
from a sort of computer science
point of view?
Obviously, it's pooling.
So these 1,000 cells are
pooling their resources
into 50 glomeruli.
So you're averaging and
you're reducing noise.
And there's also a normalization
process that goes on here.
There are lateral
connections here
that try to even out
the responses so that--
let's say at a fixed
concentration, one odor that
causes a lot of responses
in the receptors
and another odor that gives
much less response kind of get
equaled out here, so that
the strong odor doesn't
overwhelm the weaker odor.
OK, so that's this stage.
And I thought I'd show you
some of these responses.
So here are the 50.
This is not all data.
This is data plus extrapolation.
But the data comes
from a beautiful study
of Hallem and Carlson.
These would be the 50 ORNs,
types, so one of each type.
And here are 110 orders
that were tested.
And the responses in firing rate
color kind of look like this.
You can see they've
been graded here.
The responses get stronger as
you move from left to right.
That's just the way
they ordered them.
And you can see
they're quite uneven.
So here is a kind of
weak responding odors
and here are much
stronger responding odors.
So that's what's coming in.
Now, if you look at the PN
level-- now, this is not data.
This is a model.
It's a model really due to
Rachel Wilson and members
of her lab, but also
constructed by Sean Luo
and Ann Kennedy in my group.
And you can see the argument.
So basically, what's
happened is these inputs
come in and have gone through
a model that reproduces what
we think the PNs are doing.
PNs have not been tested with
this whole panel of odors.
But you can see the
normalization effect.
You notice that the activity
is spread much more equally
across these odors
than these odors.
And that's reflected in the
fact that if you measure
by various ways the dimension
of this representation,
you get about 30.
And here it goes up
a little bit to 35
because of this kind
of equalization effect,
and also some decorrelation
effect that goes on.
So there is that.
So what I've described here
is sort of the front end
of this olfactory system.
And it is completely
stereotyped.
It's a precise wiring.
I've described it to you.
It's the same in every fly.
If you look at two
neurons of the same type,
they look virtually identical.
So this is a hard-wired system.
And you would not say
there's any free will
or intelligence in this system.
It's just getting the signal in.
And you'll see a little
bit more of that later.
OK, so what about
the next level?
The next level is
the mushroom body.
So these yellow things are
the mushroom body neurons.
They're called Kenyon cells.
There are about 2,000 of them.
They come in only seven types.
So already, we sense
something's happening here.
There's something changing
about the representation.
The representation is getting
much higher dimensional.
It's something like
1,000 dimensional.
So there's a projection
out to a high dimensional
representation.
And this is where the
free will comes in.
And in anatomical terms, the
reason it does is because--
I'll try to persuade
you with the data--
that this acts exactly like
a random, high dimensional,
hidden layer in a
machine learning system.
So this guy is
suddenly a new beast.
Within one synapse,
the system's gone
from completely stereotyped
to, you know, crazy.
Completely random.
I would say there's
lots of evidence
that it's different
in every fly,
that every one of these
neurons is different.
And you've completely
given up the stereotypy.
So now, how do you
get back to sense?
Because you've built
this beautiful olfactory
representation here, and it's
as if you've thrown it out.
You've just gone crazy.
And so now, I put the box
around here just to remind us,
this is a different
beast all of a sudden.
And it's a very unusual
beast in the fly brain.
I'll come back to that.
But now you have output.
So these yellow
neurons, as you'll see,
do not leave the mushroom body.
They don't send any signal out.
They're completely intrinsic
to the mushroom body.
But there are neurons called
mushroom body output neurons
that do send the signal out.
And again, now it's
a new ballgame.
First of all, look
at the numbers.
You've gone from 2,000 neurons
to 34 neurons of 21 types.
You've got about a
20-dimensional representation.
There's been a collapse
of the representation.
So I would argue you can just
see right away from this slide
that this is an
olfactory representation.
This is an olfactory
representation cleaned up
a bit.
This is a crazy, random
olfactory representation.
This is not an olfactory
representation.
The dimension is lower
than what you started with,
so there's no way you can
represent the full thing.
This is already, somehow, making
a decision about olfaction.
It's well on the
way to a behavior.
And again, the great
thing about the fly
here is that you get
there very quickly.
If you went to Jim's
talk today, I'm
sure he talked to you
about the long pathway
in the visual
systems of monkeys,
in which these stages take up
a good fraction of your brain.
These more complicated
stages do it.
And then it's very
difficult to see
where this transition is to
decisions and things like that.
Here, the transition from
orderly input representation,
sort of retinal-like,
to IT-like,
if you want, in the visual
system occurs in one synapse.
And then the return to
a decision, a behavior,
in another synapse.
It's very quick.
And I would think of that
in computer science terms
as a readout layer.
As you'll see, it's
actually a layered system,
but it's the readout.
OK, and this system
here, it goes back
to being completely stereotyped.
There are very few neurons
per type, if you notice.
There are almost as many cell
types as there are neurons.
And they're the same
in every animal.
So you've gone from
stereotypy at the input
stage, a wild and crazy
random thing in the middle,
and then back to stereotypic
to get to the output.
Which of course, you
have to do, right?
Your motor neurons have to
go to the right muscles.
You can't randomly wire
your motor neurons.
And thinking occurs
between those.
Same thing with your retina.
It has to be wired to give
you the basic visual signal.
But between those
two extremes, that's
where we do our thinking.
And as I say, that
you can see here,
but it's in this one layer, OK?
All right, and the key is going
to be exactly as in a machine
learning system.
As you'll see, the key
to the whole system
is the plasticity and
modulation that occurs
at that set of connections.
There's no evidence that these
connections, these connections,
and these connections are
at least very plastic.
They may be modulated
a little bit,
but the business
end of this thing,
just as in many machine
learning networks,
is that the readout
unit's being adjusted.
And I will come back to that.
All right, so here,
the mushroom body,
it started out as
it was in the fly.
And as it turns, you'll see why
it's called the mushroom body.
Yeah, now it looks
like a mushroom.
So these are the cell bodies.
They receive-- you can't
really see very well here,
but they receive their input
right under the mushroom.
And then they send axons down.
And these axons form the load.
So this whole thing is
made out of Kenyon cells.
That's the Kenyon cells
all together forming
this structure.
How many cells?
A couple of thousand.
OK, now here you can see one
of the projection neurons.
Here's where it gets its
input from the antenna lobe,
goes up to the mushroom body,
goes over to the lateral horn.
And here you can see-- it's
sort of hard to distinguish
that neuropil from
the cell bodies here,
but here you can see that sort
of under this layer of cell
bodies, it's making
its connections.
And what I want to
stress here is this idea
that the projection
neurons occur
very few cells per cell type.
Now, these cells types--
I guess I'm going to get
ahead of myself a little bit.
But through work at
Janelia Farm in particular,
there have been these
intersectional strategies
for expressing various
markers in these cells.
And they've been
supremely successful.
So typically, when you get a
cell type in this business,
it's often two cells, one
on each side of the fly.
They're perfect mirror
images of each other.
And they're identical
in all flies.
So that's what you
mean by a cell type.
And in much of the fly, there
are very few of them per--
this is per side.
There will always
be an even number.
And you can see, there are 50
types, a couple hundred cells.
That's part of the
specific wiring.
Now, if you look at the Kenyon
cells, so here they are,
there are, as I mentioned, about
a couple of thousand of them.
And there are up to
600 of them per type.
It's much more like what
we think of as cortex.
We don't think of the cortex
as having millions and millions
of cell types.
Maybe thousands, but there are
many, many cells per cell type.
And that occurs here.
Very small number of cell types
relative to the other things.
And here's one of them.
It's superimposed.
So these Kenyon cells, they
have their cell body here.
They make their connections.
So they get the input from
the projection neuron,
send an axon down, which
in some cases splits.
And there are five lobes here.
There is an alpha lobe
or an alpha prime lobe
here, a beta lobe or a
beta prime lobe here.
And then some of them
send a single axon
down to a gamma lobe.
You will see that
a little bit more.
Then that's it.
That's how the mushroom body's
built. And if you notice,
they do not send anything
out of the mushroom body.
So the first thing
I want to ask, then,
is what happens at this junction
between the orderly world
of the fly, characterized
by these PNs,
and the wild and random world
of the fly, characterized
by these Kenyon sets?
Here's where they meet in this
calyx of the mushroom body.
So the experiment
that I was involved
in the data analysis of
came from Richard's lab
and was done in
the following way.
First, a single Kenyon
cell-- so here you
can see all these cell
bodies of Kenyon cells.
There are zillions
of them up there,
thousands of them up there.
But one of them has been--
the GFP in one of them has
been activated, photoactivated.
So you can see this single
Kenyon cell comes down.
Here it's making connections
to get the olfactory input
from the projection neurons.
And then the axon's
going to go down
through the floor into the
other parts that I showed you.
So the trick in this thing--
you can't see very well,
but I think I maybe made
a circle around one.
You can't see it very
well, but the terminals
of this guy, the postsynaptic
terminals, are like claws.
They're called claws.
And they grab hold of one of
the terminals of the projection
neurons and make a synapse.
So that's how they work.
This guy has about
seven of these claws,
so there are very few
connections per Kenyon cell.
The trick was for Sophie
to inject the die right
into the claw here, which
is a very tightly sealed
little microglomerulus.
And that die is taken up by
a projection neuron, the one
and only one projection neuron
that has a terminal there.
And here you can see the axon
of that projection neuron
as it makes terminals in
other parts of this calyx
and makes connections
with other Kenyon cells.
So there it is.
So that's not the
important part.
The important part is you can
trace back this projection
neuron to the antenna lobe and
see where it got its input.
And now, because
the antenna lobe
is a totally stereotyped,
structured thing,
you can now read out.
If you know the
antennal lobe, you
will know that this input
is of a certain type.
It's from a certain
set of receptors.
So you know right away that
this guy is getting input
from receptor number three,
or whoever sends projections
to that thing.
Furthermore, you can repeat
this with other terminals
of that cell, get a
whole lot of projections,
and find, essentially,
all of the inputs--
sometimes not all, but
most of the inputs--
that go to this Kenyon cell
and figure out what they are.
So in other words,
the result of this,
without doing EM or all
that, is a connectome.
It's the connection matrix
between the glomeruli,
or if you want, these
olfactory channels.
And there are 50 up around
here, plus some hot and cold
and some other stuff.
But basically, the 50
glomeruli are at the top.
And 200 Kenyon cells that were
measured going down the side.
Not all 2,000 Kenyon
cells were measured.
These are not measured
from the same animal.
But you basically get
this connectivity matrix.
A red little square here
means that this connection
was found for this Kenyon cell.
And a yellow one means
a double connection.
There were actually two
connections between that Kenyon
cell and that glomerulus.
So there's the matrix.
So then my job at this
point was say, well, what's
the structure of this matrix?
And that's a trickier problem.
I mean, you look at it by eye,
you say, well, it looks random.
It just looks like
a bunch of dots.
But what you have
to remember, and I
think this is a
really important thing
to remember in
connectomes, is connectomes
don't come labeled, all right?
So this matrix is arranged
in the following way.
This is alphabetical,
which probably is not
of fundamental
neuroscience significance.
And this is the order in
which the cells were measured,
which is also probably not
of neuroscience significance.
So the question is,
is there any way
to permute the rows and
columns of this matrix
to get a structure?
That's the question you
have to answer here.
And just let me show
you an example of that.
So here's a matrix that
I've shrunk the size a bit,
but it's exactly the
same kind of matrix.
In fact, it probably looks to
you pretty much like the data.
It doesn't have the colors,
but other than that.
So here's a data matrix.
But this one I made up.
And it turns out, of
course, I knew the trick
that if you re-sort, if you
permute the rows and columns,
it looks like this.
So just because
that looks random
does not at all mean
there's no structure there.
So you have to do
a lot of analysis
to convince yourself that
there's no structure.
So one of the first
things you could do--
random doesn't mean uniform.
So one thing you can do is
just sum down the columns here
and ask, how many connections
does each of the glomeruli
make?
And it's not uniform.
It's quite uneven.
Here's the histogram.
But really, the question
we ask is, is there
something more to it?
For example, if a Kenyon cell
gets one of these inputs,
is it more likely to also
get one of those inputs?
Are there any correlations here?
And that's really the question.
And we did a whole
lot of analysis.
And the answer's no.
I'm not going to
take you through it.
That all the tests
we could possibly
do are completely consistent
with just randomly selecting
from this probability
distribution
without independent ID,
or whatever it's called.
OK, so there are other
papers, an earlier paper
and a later paper,
that essentially
come to the same conclusion.
What's interesting about the
Murthy, Fiete, and Laurent
paper is they actually
provide some evidence
that, in fact, it's different
in different animals.
This doesn't prove that
because this is already
taken from different animals.
I'm not going to
present that evidence.
But there is
evidence that this is
different in different animals.
So this looks like
a random structure.
Now, it's interesting, you
guys, why seven connections?
Seven seems awfully small to
us cortico-centric people.
And so why seven?
Well, you can do a
following little exercise.
You can say, suppose that
the Kenyon cells only had
one connection.
Then how many duplicate
Kenyon cells would there be?
Well, there are only 50
possible types of input, right?
There are 50 types
of Kenyon grand cell.
So if you only
have one connection
and you're making
2,000 cells, you're
going to get tons of repeats,
hundreds of thousands
of pairs that are identical.
So that you would
not spread out.
Now, you can do this calculation
for two connections, three
connections, four connections.
And it goes down.
And if you look at the
line where you'd only
expect one pair to be the same,
the mushroom body-- in fact,
if you average, it's
between six and seven.
It's right in there.
The mushroom body is
right at the point
where you convince yourself
that most of the time every cell
will be different.
And then why go any further?
Some of you may know something
about the cerebellum.
These are like granule
cells of the cerebellum.
Granule cells in the
cerebellum typically
have four or five
inputs [INAUDIBLE]..
They're small cells with
claws with very few inputs.
And their axons
form parallel fibers
and then can get connected
by Purkinje cells.
This system is the
same, if you notice.
The parallel fibers
are forming the trunk
and that L-shaped region
in the mushroom body.
So these are like granule cells.
OK, so where are we?
So we've got to get a
signal out of this thing
or it's completely
useless, right?
So we've got this random
signal into this beast.
So what do the output
neurons look like?
There's an output
neuron, one of them.
And what you might
notice is it's
going to a very
compact region right
at the head of this alpha--
I don't know if this is an
alpha or an alpha prime.
But it's going to one or
the other of those lobes.
So it's very restricted
in its dendrites.
And then off it goes carrying
the signal wherever it's going.
So in fact, I tried
to argue earlier
that the output neurons
in a mushroom body
have gone back to
this other mode.
Very few cells per type.
Practically as many
types as output cells.
And a very small
number of cells.
And if you took a picture of
this cell in another animal,
it would look exactly the same.
All right, so it was known
before this Janelia work,
that if you take the
mushroom body lobe--
so this is this L-shaped
structure at the bottom,
or it's really at the front
of the mushroom body--
and you peel off the
gamma lobe, the gamma
would sit there but it would
kind of block your view.
So it's been peeled off here.
So you have this
alpha beta lobe.
That's one set of axons
that have bifurcated.
And they come in sort of
here and then bifurcate.
You have the alpha prime
beta lobe bifurcating.
And then you have
this third gamma lobe.
That divides up each of
these into five sections.
They're numbered like this,
but there are five of them, OK?
Alpha 1, 2, 3 and beta 1, 2.
So each of these guys gets
divided into five compartments.
And then there's an extra
compartment right here
called the peduncle, where--
here's the mushroom head.
Here's the stock.
And then you get this.
And right at the base of the
stock, there's another one.
And so what the Janelia
collaboration figured out
by genetically targeting
these cells very precisely.
It is summarized
by this picture.
So this shows different
types of these output
neurons in different colors.
And what you can
see is that they are
respecting the compartments.
That you have basically one
type of output neuron going
to each compartment
without overlap.
And there really is--
there's now EM level
data, and they really
don't overlap at all.
Here's kind of what it looks
like in an anatomical diagram.
Here are the Kenyon cells.
Here's the calyx where
they get their input.
Here's this L-shaped structure.
And these output neurons
respect each other's territory.
Here is the 16
compartments where they do.
And then they're very well
organized in another way.
You notice these colors here.
These colors refer
to the transmitter
of the output neuron.
So all the glutamate
guys are over here.
All the GABA guys are down here.
The cholinergic
guys are over here.
Now, again, you get this extreme
order returning to the system.
Here's a theorist's
version of this.
Here are the compartments, the
16 compartments, 5 per lobe,
plus the peduncle, which kind of
belongs to the alpha beta lobe.
Here they are, the
different compartments.
And then here are the output
cells assigned to them.
They're not necessarily
one cell per blob here.
Sometimes there are a few cells.
But basically, those
are the cell types.
And as I mentioned,
they respect--
they only go to one
compartment each.
And then those are
the transmitters,
which in this diagram,
they don't cluster nicely.
But in the other
diagram they do.
Now, you can ask, why
bother to do this?
Because there are
axons going down.
The parallel fibers that
the Kenyon cells make,
they go that way.
So all of these guys have access
to exactly the same input.
So what would it matter
if this guy decided
to send a branch over and pick
up the axon over there instead
of over there?
It would make no
difference at all.
So at this point,
you would sort of
wonder, why are they respecting
these compartments so
faithfully?
And that's answered
in this slide.
So these are the
output neurons, as you
can see, kind of tiling the
thing in these compartments.
And this is a set
of dopamine neurons,
which were also genetically
isolated in this way
and labeled, that target
these compartments.
And you notice the
perfect alignment.
So the reason these guys
are compartmentalized
is so they can be individually
modulated by dopamine.
And you can see that here.
So the dopamine
neurons come, again,
in slightly more
numbers of types.
But they align and exactly
innervate these compartments
without overlap.
So the reason the
beta 2 guy's in here
is so it can be innervated
by these particular dopamine
neurons.
The dopamine neurons are
divided into two classes.
And again, if we go to
the anatomical-- oh,
I should mention.
If you notice, there were some
missing compartments there,
but some of the dopamine
neurons go to 2,
so everybody gets covered.
If you go back to this
anatomical diagram, what
you see is everybody
over here gets
modulated by these, what are
called, PAM dopamine neurons.
And they're associated
with reward.
So when good stuff
happens, you hammer
this part of the mushroom body.
When bad stuff happens,
you hammer this part
of the mushroom body
with a different set
of what are called
PPL1 dopamine neurons.
So again, this
beautiful structure.
All right, so let me finish
elaborating this for you.
This is the basic structure.
Again, I didn't put it on at
first, but some of these guys
actually conduct
two compartments.
So it's not quite
true what I said.
But basically, that's the output
stream from the mushroom body.
And then there is a
layered system put on.
These are the
connections, but I kind of
depicted it down here
more schematically.
What you have in
this output system
is a one layer system down
here, a two layer system,
a three layer system,
and a four layer system.
So the output is actually
a four layer network,
feedforward network.
There's no recurrence
up to this point.
And all of the action occurs
on the alpha beta lobe.
The alpha beta
lobe is responsible
for long-term memories.
You could think of this as
the most sophisticated lobe.
Gamma lobe is more for
short-term memories,
has a simpler readout.
Alpha prime beta prime lobe is,
to me, kind of God knows what.
But probably somebody knows.
Anyway, but it's, again,
a simpler output system.
So it's just a beautiful system.
In part, I'm just
telling you about it
because it's beautiful.
OK, so that's the thing.
And then these outputs
go to various regions.
If you don't know the fly
brain, you don't care.
But what's interesting
is now the loop closes.
So the regions that receive
output from the mushroom body
also provide input to
the dopamine neurons.
So when the mushroom body
acts, the dopamine neurons
know about it.
And when the dopamine
neurons react,
the mushroom body
knows about it.
So you have this closed system
which finally loops together.
And the dopamine system
is a reporter of behavior.
So it tells the mushroom
body what the fly's doing.
Or also internal state,
how the fly's feeling.
I'll show you that in a second.
And then these are going
to be, obviously, some sort
of learned or
modulating responses,
modulated by this system.
You remember that these cannot
have any intrinsic meaning,
because they've gone
through a random stage here.
They cannot be assigned meaning
without some sort of learning
or instruction.
So these are learned outputs.
And so that's the system.
OK, so what does this system do?
One of the nice things
that's happened in parallel
with this anatomical advance
that I've been describing
is a behavioral advance of
what's the mushroom for.
I'll start with the
classic picture.
Mushroom body has been
studied for a long, long time.
That quote was from 1850.
And it's mostly been studied
as a classical conditioning
system, memory system.
You train a fly to
be afraid of an odor
or to be attracted to an
odor through a classical
conditioning experiment.
And here's a nice,
recent version
of that that's
quite instructive.
So in this experiment,
what you do is
you put one odor in the end of
a chamber, a very small chamber
that holds a fly.
One odor comes in one end.
One odor comes in the other end.
You pump it out in the middle.
And then you track the fly.
Flies pace back and forth.
And so the fly paces
back and forth.
But frequently, if it
doesn't like odor B,
it might come to this central
region, say, oh, that's odor B,
turn around and go back.
And so what you do is
count electronically
how many times the fly
crosses these boundaries.
And you can get a
measure of its preference
for being in the A
end or the B end.
And this is experiments done in
Gero Miesenboeck's laboratory.
Now, what you can do then is--
in the first set of
experiments that I'll show you,
they just look at
the innate preference
of the fly for an odor,
without any training.
That's due to the lateral
horn, as you'll see.
But then you can associate
one of the odors,
for example, with
an electric shock.
And presumably, the fly
is going to then associate
that odor with
danger and avoid it.
So here's the data.
No, first I guess I
built a little model.
So it's been long suspected
how this could work.
This is quite easy.
You have-- there are
the Kenyon cells.
Here's a mushroom
body, output neuron.
Here's a dopamine neuron.
So an odor comes along-- that's
the conditioned stimulus--
activates some Kenyon cells.
Then the unconditioned stimulus
comes along, the shock.
That activates the
dopamine neuron.
And where you have activity
plus dopamine, for example,
you strengthen the synapses.
There's evidence
that it actually
might work by weakening the
synapses, but for this diagram,
I strengthen the synapses, OK?
Then, later on, when
the odor comes along,
it activates the same set.
Now you have these
strengthened synapses.
You activate the mushroom
body output neuron
and you send an alarm signal.
So that's just classical
conditioning with this system.
And here are the data
showing it works.
So first of all, this is
the innate preference.
What's interesting--
the reason I
included this
later experiment is
because they looked at the
innate preference as well
as the learned preference.
So this is just
showing you that this
is the distance between the
PN activity for these odors.
So this is a measure of
the discriminability.
And they sort of argue
that these odors which
have a zero
preference maybe can't
be distinguished by the fly.
You don't know that,
but any rate, zero
means they're equally
likely to go to both ends.
So these odors, they don't care.
But when the odors
are quite different,
they can have a fairly
strong preference
for one odor over the other.
Now you train, and
suddenly you have
a strong preference or a strong
avoidance, a preference for one
over the one that was
associated with shock.
And now what they
did was genetically--
I mentioned that we
now have genetic access
to all these cells.
One of the things you can do
is block synaptic transmission
from all the Kenyon cells.
So you just wipe out the
output of the mushroom body.
That's done by raising the
temperature of these flies.
And suddenly, they go right
back to their innate preferences
as if they'd never
learned something.
But they still can
sense the odor.
They still have their
innate preference,
almost identical to
what it was before.
But they've lost.
Now, if you cool
down these flies,
they'll pop back up to there.
OK, that's classical
conditioning.
Oh, I know what I was
going to mention here.
Not in these experiments,
but in other experiments,
you can replace
the electric shock
by an activation of
the dopamine neuron.
So you can show that these
avoidance type dopamine
neurons really do convey the
avoidance message, because you
can train them to avoid
odor B when all they got
was an activation, let's say
an optogenetic activation
of a dopamine neuron.
That's been done tons now.
OK, so here's another example.
As I said, I think the classic
literature on the fly is that.
It's classical conditioning
studied in zillions of ways,
looking at the molecular
basis, et cetera, et cetera.
But here's some
more newer results.
Here's one from Daisuke
Hattori in Richard's lab.
It involves this alpha
prime 3 lobe, just
to show you what it is.
And it has the
following features.
So it's a little
hard to see, maybe,
but this is a pulse that
shows that the odor, which
is MCH here, the odor
has been introduced.
And here is the response of this
alpha prime 3 output neuron.
So there you're
seeing a response.
And if you look across time,
that response fades away.
It even starts to reverse maybe.
So there's an adaptation
of this response.
You say, big deal.
But this adaptation
is definitely
occurring at the output
of the mushroom body.
The Kenyon cells
are not adapting.
It's due to the dopamine,
because if you block
the dopamine you don't get it.
So this is dopamine
specific adaptation.
But what's more interesting
about it is shown here,
that if you take an odor
response to MCH, adapt it
away, but then
present a new odor,
benzaldehyde, now you
get a response again.
Then you can adapt the way the
response of the benzaldehyde
and introduce a third
order, you get a thing.
So this is an
odor-dependent adaptation,
which really suggests that
the dopamine is specifically
weakening the synapses
that are active at the time
of the dopamine response.
So it's like the
classical conditioned,
but there's no
conditioning here.
Furthermore, when you adapt
one odor and then another,
the first order remains adapted.
So I sort of see this system--
I've always had trouble
with the classical condition
experiments, imagining
where would a fly
get into a situation
where it smells an odor
and gets a shock, or
something like that?
But this, you can immediately
see, would be very useful.
You could adapt
to an environment
that has a whole set of odors.
And then if you come
back to that environment
and there's a new
odor present, you'll
immediately know it,
because this neuron
is going to respond.
Whereas if you come back to
the identical environment,
or without new odors,
this won't respond.
So this is a neuron to
identify unexpected olfactory
features of an environment.
Or it's one thing it could do.
OK, I think I just repeated that
because I wanted to say that.
Here's another example.
This comes from Raphael
Cohn and Vanessa Ruta's lab.
And this is really the
effect of internal state.
So I argued for you that
these dopamine neurons
were reflecting the internal
state of the animal.
And they have a very
beautiful experiment on that.
So these are the gamma.
I guess I didn't say
before, but these
are the gamma 2 through
gamma 5 compartments
that we're going to talk about.
What they did was to
image the dopamine
neurons in those compartments,
gamma 2, 3, 4, and 5,
and observed that
when the fly is--
the fly is in an
uncomfortable position,
to put it mildly here.
It's glued to something,
I don't know what.
And there's a hole in its head.
Other than that,
everything's fine.
So it's an unhappy fly.
You might want to speculate
that this is an unhappy fly.
And what they observed
is while the fly is
flailing about and unhappily
expressing its unhappiness,
these gamma 2 and
gamma 3 compartments
have dopamine input.
And the gamma 4
and gamma 5 don't.
But they also observed
that every once in a while,
the fly just chills out,
hangs there, like, oh Christ.
And when that happens,
it reverses the pattern.
Now these are not
dopamine activated
and these ones are
dopamine modulated.
Although this is not
unequivocal happiness.
This is mixed.
But then they
started manipulating.
So here, you take one
of these unhappy flies,
you give it some sugar, it
becomes a happy fly, right?
Remember, the red over
here, this is a happy fly.
This is a sad fly,
because they shocked it.
So it's clear that this
thing is really reading a--
they'll be a little fanciful--
but happy fly, sad fly.
You could take a look at
these compartments and say,
that is one unhappy
fly, or one happy fly.
Furthermore, now, so that
means the internal state
is being represented here.
But in addition,
it has an effect.
So this is an
experiment where they
imaged the output term, the
dendrites of the output neuron.
So they're looking at
transmission from the Kenyon
cell to the output neuron.
They present an odor.
And they activate the
dopamine neuron themselves.
So when they don't activate
the dopamine neuron,
this is a measure of
synaptic transmission.
The odor response here is weak.
When they do, it
gets much stronger.
So now what you
have is something--
I mean, I think if I saw
this in cortex, I'd go wild--
is a gating effect.
You have internal state
affecting the thing of this,
and it determines
where the output goes.
So for example, if you're--
I can never remember
which one's happy.
This is happy, right?
So if you're happy, then
odors go to one thing, which
might say, approach that order.
You know, be sort of a
little more easy going.
If you're unhappy, then an
odor response gets relayed out
this pathway.
And it might tell you to
be afraid of all odors,
or something like that.
Be very cautious.
So you start to
see in this system
the routing of sensory
information by internal states.
That, to me, is a very
exciting thing to see.
OK, here's another one--
internal state affects memory.
This is from Tanimoto, another
collaboration with the Janelia
lab.
So you can do the same
kind of experiment
I showed you before with
shock, only do it with sweet.
So in this case, it's a T maze.
A fly comes in this way.
And you associate, let's say,
odor A with a sweet reward.
Then the fly is going to come
in here and most of the time
go this way.
Flies are never 100%
performers, but they'll
tend to go to odor A because
they associate that with sweet,
provided they're hungry.
I'll come back to
the hungry part.
So you take a hungry
fly, it goes this way.
Now, here's what they
did that's very clever.
It involves these PAM
neurons, PAM dopamine neurons.
So as you all know, you get
the hit of sugar in your mouth
right away.
And then you get
nutritional value,
or you get fat or
whatever later.
And the decoupling of those
causes us a lot of problems.
So you see that here
in this system very,
very well, because they take
a sugar that's sweet tasting
to the fly but can't be digested
by the fly, that provides
no nutritional value at all.
And when they do that--
so there's no nutrition
in this sugar--
what they get is a short-term
attraction to that odor,
enough to buy the
next Coke, sort of.
It's conveyed
through octopamine,
so the sweetness
activates octopamine.
Octopamine activates a certain
set of these PAM neurons.
That makes changes
in the transmission
in various compartments.
This is not isolated to
a unique compartment.
Then the next time that odor
comes on, it goes out here
and it gives you attraction.
But it's a short-term
attraction, lasts a few hours.
Now, if you make the
sugar nutritious--
and they do this in a clever way
by using another sugar that has
no taste to the fly but
that the fly can digest,
so now this nutritious--
then it activates a fructose
receptor, blah, blah, blah,
activates a different
set of dopamine neurons.
That potentiates or depresses--
we don't actually know--
but it changes synapses
in the alpha 1 lobe.
And now you get a
long-term memory.
So flies are smarter
than people in a way.
They'll only do this
long-term memory
if they then also sense
a nutritional benefit
to whatever they're eating.
OK, so very elegant thing.
And then I think this
is my final example--
I'll start winding up--
from Scott Waddell's
lab, that another feature
of this sweet thing is
if the fly's not hungry,
not surprisingly, it
doesn't care anymore.
So it's associated odor A with
sweet, but now it's well-fed,
so who cares.
And that's a real effect.
So a fed fly will not
express this odor preference.
But it still has the memory,
because if you then starve it,
now it will go to odor A.
OK, So what Scott Waddell
and his group realized
was that this was activated
through this dopamine neuron.
Now, this was done before all
this circuitry was derived.
But they figured it out that
it's this dopamine neuron,
because they could activate
this dopamine neuron
and simulate the fed state, so
the fly would ignore the odor.
Or they could silence
this dopamine neuron
and then they would
simulate the hungry state
and the fly would be
attracted to the odor.
But now, you notice
this circuitry,
this is a GABAergic
neuron that inhibits
the alpha beta lobe output.
So this is a perfect
pathway by which
you could turn off the learned
response in this during the fed
state.
And then you inactivate
this pathway,
and now you turn it on.
So again, an internal
state gating a memory.
But it's a case--
we don't really know that
everything I'm saying is true.
One should never assume that.
But we now have this pathway.
People-- we, I say, but people,
we can block this pathway.
There's enough known about the
circuitry to really work out
that what I said is
true, that you can
start to get at these things.
So one-- yeah, I got a
minute to do CO2 avoidance.
CO2 avoidance is
a really cool one.
So CO2 is innately
repulsive to a fly.
It doesn't like CO2.
And the reason that
is is in a group
of flies that are stressed,
they release a lot of CO2.
So a fly will sense CO2, know
there's trouble in the area,
and will avoid it.
So there's a natural avoidance
through the innate pathway
to CO2.
Now, that's kind of a fatal
flaw in the design of the fly,
because flies eat rotting fruit
that releases tons of CO2.
So you don't want to
avoid your food source.
So what happens-- it's
not completely understood.
But somehow, the innate system
trains this beta 2 pathway
to have, in addition to the
innate pathway, a learned
pathway for CO2 avoidance.
And in the hungry state,
the fly channels its CO2--
it still has CO2 avoidance.
It channels it
through this pathway.
Then if, at the same time,
there are fruit odors or fruit
tastes, it can
modulate this pathway,
shut it down, and
turn the CO2 avoidance
into a CO2 attraction.
So again, you start to
see the neural substrates
of these really quite complex
behaviors sitting right
before you in this structure.
All right, I'll
end here with sort
of the lesson for
the machine learners.
So from a machine
learning perspective,
this is a simple system.
It's not very deep.
It's a little bit deep,
but not very deep.
It contains a random
hidden representation.
That's not really
anything radical.
It contains a set
of output neurons.
It's actually a layered output.
Again, nothing very radical.
In neuroscience term,
it's kind of interesting
that it goes from these highly
stereotyped to random to highly
stereotyped.
But really, the
lesson here is this
is a mediocre machine
learning architecture.
Not very many
units and all that.
Where does this
thing make up for it?
It makes up for it
in a stupendous,
complicated modulation and
plasticity beyond any machine
learner's dreams.
We don't know about this.
I tried to give you hints of
the different things it can do.
Dopamine can gate.
It can induce
short-term learning.
long-term learning.
It can induce gating of
gating, gating of learning.
That's what has to be
worked out in this system.
But there's going to be a really
beautiful effect of dopamine
acting in many ways
on many time scales.
And to me, in this
system, that's
where evolution has put
its money, right there.
Not in building 20 layers
here or something like that.
Not in worrying about a
whole lot of back prop.
This is random.
It doesn't appear
to be back propped.
But in putting huge resources
into a rich set of modulatory
and plastic processes at
these output synapses.
And I think in the years to
come, they will be worked out.
And maybe they'll
have implications
for machine learning once
we know what they are.